cuál es el impacto en materia política
del restablecimiento de estas relaciones
qué imagen deja esta decisión del
presidente entrante gustado petro cuando
otros mandatarios de izquierda de la
región como gabriel boric han mantenido
la distancia con el gobierno de maduro
buenas noches gracias por la invitación
bueno en primer lugar es diría que el
impacto ciertamente es positivo
pues ciertamente un paso que era
necesario para la reconciliación para el
restablecimiento de las relaciones entre
los países que pues han sido importantes
históricamente desde el priísta
económico político pero sobre todo
comercial
si bien pues usted dice que por y si el
gobierno porque se ha mantenido
a instancias del gobierno maduro pues en
ese sentido colombia y venezuela que es
países fronterizos pues no lo podrían
hacer tanto entonces creo que es
conveniente esa es restablecer las
relaciones en la medida en que beneficia
a los departamentos a los estados
fronterizos tanto del táchira como
santander
e incluso otros estados como por ejemplo
en venezuela
estados como el mismo táchira es el que
más beneficia pero pero sí creo que es
positivo por puntos hablando en temas de
inmigración como afectar esta medida la
zona fronteriza
no esto es importantísimo piense usted
que en venezuela entre la frontera entre
venezuela y colombia actualmente hay
entre 260 y 280 pasos fronterizos
ilegales y sólo 5 empleados regulares
entonces pues eso significaría
una digamos desincentivación
que no se cree más incentivos para que
los bachaqueros o los polos o aquellos
que manejaban esos pasos fronterizos
pues tengan esa esa posibilidad entonces
es desarticular digamos a esas bandas
ilegales que funcionaban de lado y lado
en los dos pasos
se trata entonces de asegurar esas
30.000 personas
promedio a diario con esos pasos
ilegales pues puedan hacerlo de una
manera legal de una manera regular y le
pregunta brevemente usted ha hablado de
la materia económica cómo se ha manejado
la frontera hasta este momento y qué se
espera con el restablecimiento de las
relaciones
pues la frontera ciertamente es a los
dos de lado y lado ha habido pérdidas
por supuesto en términos comerciales en
términos económicos y esto significaría
pues que las mercancías de parte y parte
pues podrían pasar mucho más fácilmente
y se restablecerían digamos anteriores
relaciones comerciales que beneficiaban
a los dos países por ejemplo colombia
antes de 2009 era claramente un
exportador de automóviles hacia
venezuela y venezuela pues a
productos cárnicos
y otros productos digamos típicos de
venezuela entonces se reactivaría
claramente la economía y eso redundaría
por supuesto de manera benéfica para los
dos países